hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math
more fun and less stressful so in this
video what we're going to talk about is
how to find the volume of prisms and
cylinders okay so what is a prism okay
and what is a cylinder
well prism is basically a three
dimensional object okay where you've got
two bases okay that are the same size
and shape okay
they're so they're congruent and they're
parallel meaning if they were to keep
going they're not going to cross so
they're parallel congruent bases
separated by the height okay so that's
what a prism is cylinder is basically
the exact same thing okay it looks like
a can of some sort you can almost think
of it as a circular prism the top and
bottom are circles okay and it's
separated by the height okay and the two
circles are parallel and congruent so
the formulas really easy it's the area
of the base times the height so the
capital B means the area of the base so
not the length of the base but the
actual two-dimensional area times the
height so what you could think of is you
could think of this as a triangle and
you're stacking up these triangles on
top of one another until you get a
three-dimensional object so it's like a
sticky notes you know a notepad you
stack them up that gives you the third
dimension that gives you the volume
three-d right okay so if we find them
let's look at this example if we find
the volume of this triangular prism okay
now notice the the dots here the dashes
that just means that we're looking
through the object to the other side so
that we can kind of get that sense of 3d
on a flat surface okay but let's go and
find the volume on this one it's the
area of the base times the height now
what I like to do is I like to write
down the formula and you might want to
do the same thing too but then what we
can do is we can subdivide the formula
so the area of the base that's a
triangle what's the formula for area of
a triangle it's one half base times
height times the height again okay so
let's not get confused there's a lot of
bees have a lot of H's right so the the
capital B means the area of this base
the area of this triangle the little B
means the length of the base so the base
here in this triangle is either three or
four okay three could be the base and
four could be the height of the triangle
kind of like this
see three and four okay and then the
height okay the overall prison is the
ten that's what's separating the two
triangles that you parallel congruent
bases so if we put these values in we
have one half three times four and then
the overall height is ten if we multiply
all those together we get 3 times 4 is
12 times 10 is 120 times 1/2 or divided
by 2 is going to give you 60 units cubed
so cubed means we're filling this up
with like little ice cubes you know so
to speak like that how many of those
little cubes would fill up the inside of
this container ok the next example we're
going to talk about the volume of a
cylinder now I just want to say if
you're enjoying these videos go ahead
and subscribe to the channel and I've
got more videos like this coming for you
and you can take a check out some of my
past videos but let's look at this last
example cylinder ok same idea we're
going to find the volume so it's the
area of the base times the height the
bases of circle what's the formula for
area of a circle it's PI R squared right
so and then times the height so the
overall height we know is 10 we know
what pi is a 3.14 and then the radius is
the distance from the center of the
circle to a point on the circle so they
give us that that's 4 4 squared so
remember you want to do the order of
operations parentheses exponents
multiplication right so 4 squared is 16
times 10 is 160 and we'll just leave
pius pi so that'll give us an exact
answer 160 PI units cubed we're filling
this up with like little ice cubes is
this glass okay
so again I hope you're enjoying the
videos go ahead and comment below and
let me know what you liked about the
videos and maybe what I could do better
to improve the videos and I look forward
to seeing you in the future
future videos I'll talk to you soon